[Musique]
bio lui ravi de vous retrouver sous ce
beau soleil hivernal fabriquer tester
rêver c'est ce que vous a proposé le
festival open campus qui s'est déroulé
juste derrière moi au poteau 204 c'était
la première édition nous y étions
fabriquer tester rêver c'est ce que nous
allons faire dans ce nouveau numéro de
paris saclay tv fabriquer et logement
les entreprises pour convaincre les
investisseurs paris saclay a mis en
place une rencontre territoire
d'opportunités un rendez vous inédit qui
a réuni plus de 250 professionnels de
l'immobilier restait le plug in labs une
plate forme qui vous donne accès aux 300
laboratoires de recherche que court le
territoire une opportunité pour les
entreprises innovantes
nous verrons comment enfin rêver avec
port de bassens
cette start-up local réinvente la ville
durable et vous propose de découvrir la
nature cachée de votre territoire
grâce à une application sur smartphone
c'est tout simple ça s'appelle big up
enfin notre agenda tous les événements à
ne pas rater dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent ce sera bien sûr à
la fin de cette émission
on commence avec cette rencontre
organisée par le pea paris saclay et vos
élus à saint quentin en yvelines
un rendez vous inédit territoire
d'opportunités a permis de réunir plus
de 250 professionnels de l'immobilier
avec un objectif promouvoir le cluster
paris saclay
[Musique]
evènement c'est d'abord une rencontre
une rencontre entre les élus et
l'établissement public et les
professionnels de l'immobilier pour
permettre de valoriser tout le potentiel
qui existe sur notre territoire le
territoire de paris saclay qui
aujourd'hui travaillent collectivement
tous ensemble on est tous autour de la
table
et puis on a envie de profiter des 15%
de recherche publique des 15% de
recherches privées qui sont concentrés
sur notre plateau et faire en sorte que
cette recherche donne des fruits donnent
des fruits économiques qu'il y ait là
des entreprises en croissance qui se
développe sur notre territoire d'être en
quelque sorte une silicon valley à la
française
donc on a beaucoup d'opportunités que
qui vont de saint quentin en passant par
versailles vélizy courtaboeuf massy orly
le plateau de saclay bien autour du cas
le tuer ce qu'est le coeur du dispositif
à une opération internationale on a
besoin de partenaires privés et on fait
en sorte que l'on travaille tous
ensemble les élus les partenaires pour
faire une réussite de ce territoire
ces professionnels de l'immobilier qui
sont présents aujourd'hui des
des promoteurs des investisseurs des
personnes qui s'intéressent au
développement du logement du logement en
général du logement étudiant de
l'immobilier d'entreprise
on a beaucoup de d'excellents
professionnels qui sont présents c'est
une grande réussite pleurait
[Musique]
pourquoi investir ici et bien déjà parce
que paris saclay concentre 15% de la
recherche française et maintenant il
suffit d'un simple clic pour avoir accès
aux quelques 300 laboratoires que compte
votre territoire
une opportunité pour les entreprises
innovantes ce sésame s'appelle plug in
l'aps c'est une plateforme collaborative
démonstration avec jessica péricaud elle
est chef de projet
[Musique]
plug in as donc c'est une plateforme de
collaboration entre les laboratoires de
recherche publique de l'université parix
accès et les entreprises
le but c'est de faciliter la connexion
entre ces deux acteurs sur le territoire
paris saclay donc le village est un
outil ou une plateforme web qui est son
cas sur un moteur de recherche par mots
clés ou par thématique par domaines
d'innovation
on peut ainsi accéder à tout le
potentiel de recherche les expertises
les compétences les équipements de
l'université paris saclay donc ça donne
accès aux utilisateurs et notamment aux
pme potentiel d'innovation des
laboratoires de la recherche ce qui peut
être difficile à entrevoir donc cette
plateforme offre un point d'entrée
unique sur tout ces expertises pour
chaque laboratoire et chaque plateforme
technologique donc par mots clés on peut
trouver facilement des compétences ou
des équipements si j'entre par exemple
pollution la base va aller
nous chercher tous les laboratoires qui
corresponde à ce mot clé et on accède
rapidement donc fiche des laboratoires
qui correspondent à la recherche par
exemple sur cette fiche laboratoire on
va avoir rapidement les informations sur
laboratoire de manière synthétique pour
comprendre un peu ce que fait le
laboratoire et on a la possibilité
d'observer
l'offre de technologie qui propose pour
évaluer un peu son potentiel
d'innovation
il ya également possibilité de les
contacter directement depuis la
plateforme en utilisant ce simple bouton
pour contacter le responsable soit du
laboratoire soit la plateforme
technologique
donc c'est un site qui est disponible en
version française mais également en
version anglaise sont se limitent pas au
territoire paris saclay le but c'est
vraiment que tout utilisateur d'où qu'il
vienne puisse entrevoir le potentiel de
nuitées paris saclay de ses laboratoires
une cet outil plus qu'une simple
plateforme internet c'est également une
équipe derrière qui permet de répondre
aux besoins qui nous sont adressées
quand la mise en relation ne se fait pas
facilement
il ya parfois besoin de travailler le
besoins technologiques de l'entreprise
et ainsi l'entreprise peut nous
contacter directement et al assad paris
saclay on est chargé de dd à
répondre aux besoins technologiques et
donc si il n'est pas évident par la
simple recherche sur ces laboratoires
sur ses fiches synthétiques de trouver
réponse à un besoin
on va aller creuser derrière pour vous
aider à trouver
quelque chose de plus convenable quelque
chose qui correspond vraiment à votre
besoin d'innovation
fabriquée tester rêver c'était le
programme alléchant du festival open
campus qui s'est tenu ici au proto 204
c'était la première édition de la
littérature au cinéma en passant par la
culture numérique les jeux vidéo ou
encore les nouvelles façons d'enseigner
les organisateurs ont voulu nous faire
réfléchir
regardez
[Musique]
le festival open campus a lieu du 6 au
10 novembre 2010 c'est avec l'objectif
de proposer aux usagers de venir tester
fabriquer river le campus pendant une
semaine donc on a fait cinq thématiques
sur la culture tout d'abord lundi on va
revenir le bus le proto bus sur le
campus et parler de librairies et 2 des
mystères de l'univers avec hervé dole
pour une popup livre éric est aussi le
soir faire un cinéma mobile avec
stéphanie mille avec des projections de
films dont certains partiront en
sélection pour les oscars
le mardi on a voulu se concentrer sur
les pratiques collaboratives et mise en
place par des chercheurs qui essaye
d'accompagner d'autres chercheurs sur
des enjeux numériques que sont le big
data
le cloud computing et la fabrication
numérique tout ça pour les aider à faire
ou développer leurs recherches mercredi
d'une progression peut être plus
habitant faut refaire ce lien là en tout
cas sur la thématique de l'éducation et
comment apprendre dans un écosystème
libre et plusieurs projets le learning
center de paris saclay évidemment en
tant que bâtiment qui repensé la biotech
y repenser l'accès à la connaissance à
travers des programmations particulière
mais aussi des associations et des
programmes individuels
je pense notamment à l'école
démocratique de marie gervais qui a
projet de monter une école avait tout et
un nouveau maire de repenser l éducation
en mettant l'élève le plus possible en
situation de liberté
plus je dis voir c'était un vrai un peu
professionnelle si on peut dire on a
voulu se poser la question à nous mêmes
c'est quoi les tirs l'au-delà campus à
quoi ça sert
et qu'est ce qu'on pense à plusieurs
enfin aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous
voyez derrière c'est alexis notre fab
lab manager qui fait une formation à la
réalité virtuelle pour que justement les
jeunes habitants mais aussi des
étudiants viennent apprendre à faire
leur propre environnement de réalité
virtuelle par eux mêmes cette année
c'était la première édition du festival
et on a bien sûr envie de recommencer le
retour qu'on en a ce sentiment d'être un
peu en famille il a pas avoir pu montrer
des porteurs de communauté qui agissent
que les jours sur le campus et notamment
ici au proto et mettre en avant comment
est-ce qu'un lieu peut aider des gens
qui agissent sur le territoire et donner
envie à d'autres de continuer à
s'impliquer sur les projets qui a ici
vous avez toujours rêvé de découvrir la
nature cachée de votre territoire et
bien sûrs bassin cela fait pour vous
cette start-up locale vous propose un
parcours numérique via une application
sur smartphone
rencontre avec les fondateurs de cette
start up
abbas n c'est une jeune entreprise créée
en 2015 dont le métier est de déployer
des capteurs dans les espaces de nature
en ville dans les espaces publics est
ensuite utilisé les données issues de
ces capteurs à travers différents usages
que ce soit dessiné son du jardinier
pour faire en sorte qu'on n'est plus
d'efficience dans la gestion de la
nature en ville ou pour l'utilisateur
final de ces espaces dans lesquels on
cherche à créer de nouveaux usages de
prise de conscience de connaissance des
espaces de nature en ville et surtout
des êtres vivants qu'il est qui les
habitent ces espaces de nature en ville
c'est l'objectif
notre client ici et l'aménageur paris
saclay avec qui on a tissé une relation
petit à petit de confiance et à qui on a
pu proposer une prestation innovante qui
est toujours appuyé sur des capteurs
déployés dans l'environnement mais qui
ont une autre finalité que celle de
l'économie d'eau qui est davantage celle
du porter à connaissance de la
biodiversité et des animaux qui habitent
les espaces naturels qui nous entoure
donc la première étape était
l'acquisition de contenus médias photos
et vidéos dans les espaces naturels donc
principalement les espaces boisés autour
de polytechnique la zac du moulin à la
recherche d'animaux qui se déplace
plutôt la nuit donc qui sont très
difficiles à observer comme par exemple
des renards abdellah parrain des
hérissons l'objectif était d'acquérir
ces médias pour les rediffuser ensuite
aux usagers des espaces de nature et
donc on a choisi une portion de trajet
régulièrement empruntée par une partie
des habitants du plateau qui se situe
entre la gare rer et le haut du plateau
avec
l'école polytech sur ce trajet nous
avons disposé des balises qui sont
accessibles depuis une application
smartphone et qui permettent de
récupérer en passant à côté de la balise
les médias que nous avons récemment
acquis dans les bois alentour ces
contenus seront renouvelés chaque jour
et pour chacune des balises ce qui
permet d'avoir une expérience renouvelée
à chaque passage
je vous invite tous acteurs du plateau
de saclay à venir découvrir le parcours
biodiversité que nous avons mis en place
sur le plateau
que va-t-il se passer sur votre
territoire dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent place à notre
agenda
nous parlions d'environnement de ville
durable avec urban et bien un séminaire
sur le changement climatique se tient le
13 décembre au centre scientifique
d'orsay le thème de cette deuxième
séance météorologie de l'espace et puis
ce rendez-vous l'année prochaine le 22
février 2018 ce sera à l'ensta paristech
pour les rencontres innovation une
journée d' échanges entre chercheurs et
ingénieurs start up et grandes
entreprises
voilà c'est terminé pour cet agenda
s'est terminée aussi pour ce paris
saclay tv on se retrouve très vite pour
un prochain numéro
merci de votre fidélité et d'ici là
restez informé sur notre site
au puy aps point fr mais aussi sur tv 78
merci
[Musique]